- Zuerst wird eine Idee für
einen Artikel vorgeschlagen
und dann mit der
Redaktionsleitung besprochen.
Hey, Harry, den letzten Schnaps
gestern gut verkraftet?
Erst dann beginnen die Reporter zu
recherchieren und Interviews zu machen.
Dann werden die Artikel geschrieben.
Danach wird lektoriert.
Zum Schluss werden dann alle Artikel
zusammengefasst von den Grafikern.
Und dann erst geht das
Ganze in den Druck.
- Wow … Das klingt nach viel Arbeit.
- Natürlich. Wir sind alle Profis.
Und wir wollen's auch gar nicht anders.
Das hier ist die Lokalredaktion
– das Herz der Zeitung.
- Ich möchte mich noch
einmal sehr bedanken,
dass die Anzeige kostenlos
abgedruckt wird.
- Gar kein Problem.
Dafür ist man Chef, nicht wahr?
Da kann man hin und wieder auch mal
jemandem einen Gefallen tun.
- Ich weiß das wirklich sehr zu schätzen.
- Wir können ja mal einen Kaffee
trinken gehen, wenn Sie wollen.
Ich zahl' auch! Also, klar. Ich mein,
das ist ja etwas Gutes. Nicht wahr?